Continuing in the chapter regarding the
sunan.
So, the sunan here meaning the
preferred, encouraged
aspects, elements of wudu.
And the
things that perfect
a person's wudu.
The things that complete, the finishing
touches on this great worship of wudu.
The final thing the author mentions
is making two raka'
after
wudu. This is referred to by the fuqaha
as sunnat al-wudu.
Sunnat al-wudu meaning performing two
raka'
for the occasion of making wudu.
The first evidence for this is the
narration of Uthman at the very
beginning of the book of wudu. The very
beginning of the book, the chapter of
wudu
in which Uthman narrates that the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
performed wudu.
And then upon completion
he said
[Silence]
He said whoever makes his wudu as I have
here
and then stands and prays two
units of prayer, two raka'
and does not lose his focus
in this and does not stray
in his mind
from his prayer, what is past of his
[Arabic recitation]
One of the
important patterns to recognize is that
reward
is based on the effort
or the practice that goes into earning
the reward. When you find a narration
that mentions an extremely high reward
then this means that the action itself
is rather difficult to achieve.
It's either because
a person is prone to forgetfulness
or because a person must practice for a
long a lot of
times in order to reach this level of
perfection. In this case, it is the
latter.
Meaning a person in order to achieve
this level of determination, this level
of focus in his prayer that he can make
two raka'
completely
watch the world melt away
for his two raka'.
Not a single moment his mind strays from
his prayer. This is something that takes
much determination and quite a bit of
mental fortitude to do.
As a matter of fact, I would wager that
many
if not
most
people have never
accomplished this, have never felt this,
have never experienced
such a feat. Making two raka' never
having strayed
in your salah at all. Person only
the world only comes back into focus
once the person makes tasleem. This is
quite a feat. And for this reason,
whoever is able to do this, what is past
of his sins will be forgiven.
What's interesting about this is that
every one of us has the ability to do
this.
There's no one
no one. You have never met someone
who is more stressed, more pressed,
more
under pressure than the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam and his
companions. You've just never met that
person. They don't exist.
And so,
as much as we pray,
and as much practice as we should be
having, we should be able to do this
constantly. The companions of radi
[Arabic recitation]
had perfected their prayers so much
that they would use salah in place
of anesthesia
when pulling out and treating battle
wounds.
In place of anesthesia.
So,
there's an arrow, we've got to pull this
arrow out, we have to do some stitching,
we have to
you know, we have to
we have to cauterize with with fire a
wound.
They would stand to make salah and have
it done during salah. Why? Because
their focus in prayer is so strong, the
[Arabic recitation]
would
not feel it or feel it far less and be
distracted far less
during salah.
You
Yeah, Bilal.
I could be
for any
We
[Arabic recitation]
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam said to Bilal
Bilal is mu'adhin. Bilal
ibn Rabah
and the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam had four mu'adhins. He had
four.
One in Quba one in Mecca and two in
Medina.
Bilal radiAllahu anhu was one of these
four and the one that was most usually
making adhan in Medina.
He said to him, "Ya Bilal
tell me about
the an act of worship that you do that
you are most hopeful
in Islam will be most rewarding for
you."
You know, what act of worship are you
most
confident in?
He says, "Because I heard the sound of
your footsteps in front of me in
paradise."
Now, he said this to him and the salat
subh.
Abu Hurairah says he said this to him
obviously publicly in front of the
companions
at salat subh. This is important because
whenever he would have a dream
he would always tell the companions
immediately after fajr of salah. Always.
And this was the time when he would most
usually explain the dreams of the
companions specifically after fajr of
salah on Jumu'.
The prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
when he would finish salah, he would sit
down and he would say, "Mar ra'a minkum
ru'yan laylah?"
Who of you has seen
a vision, a premonition
tonight, this week? They would tell him,
and he would share with them any dreams
that he had, because his dreams are
revelation.
He says, "I heard
your footsteps in front of me in
paradise."
Bilal responded, "I have not done
anything
which I am more hopeful and banking on
the most
except more than
making it my
custom that anytime I make wudu,
anytime I purify myself for prayer,
whether it's a a time of day or night,
except that I will make salah afterward
as much as I can, as much
as is appropriate for
the time." So, at least two rak'ahs,
sometimes more.
And so, this narration, the narration
before it, and many narrations it,
is one of the instances where it is the
sunnah to make salah upon doing so,
which is making wudu. And if a person
makes ghusl, and it takes the place of
wudu, which we will get to inshallah in
the coming chapters, then it has the
ruling of wudu. As'al Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala an yaghfir lana khatayana wa an
yatuba alayna wa an yaj'ala as-salata
qurrata a'yunina wa an yaj'ala
[Arabic recitation]